également. Voyez décorum, des
cornemuses, on est entré, Mme
Plante
vêtu. Anie Stu. Anie Stu. Anie c
Fernant pas revu depuis la
fameuse soirée. Comment allez-
- ça va bien vous?
- ça va très bien. Vous avez eu
- J'en ai eu cette fois, c'est
toujours impressionnant, c'est
toujours le fun. Ce soir y en a
quelques-uns qui ne seront pas
là à cause de comptage.
- Si tu normal, ça, et on a vu
de Montréal. Luc, c'est normal?
- servez plusieurs fois des
cérémonies de fermentation du
monde ne soit pas présent,reurss
comme ça...
- c'est parce que il y avait des
comptages. Pour moi je n'a
jamais vu ça de r
rapport à l'élection de 2005 où
il y avait le vote électronique,
mais ça, 39 où on se tro on se e
colonne, il est certainement
quelqument.
- OK, on va voir la suite des
choseste commence son
mandat avec une histoire
épouvantable. Le meurtre de cege
demande aux paree à
seuls par le parc. Prenez la rue
éclairée. Est-ce que on n'en est
- ça, igne de
ghettoïsation. On a passe dans
une ville qui fonctionne bien.
de sortir la nuit. Je me rigole
un esprit de C pes
semaines. Mais c'est un signe
dangereux et inquiétant.
Effectivement, c'était par
parle, je lui dirai de ne plus y
aller. Je lui dirai de rentrert.
- Et Annie, on parle de Montréal
du quat-Michel.
- En parle du quartier où je
suis né ou j'étais maintenant
plusieurs années. Quartierune ss
jeuness groupes
communautaires il faut comparer
la prévention. M
prévention ne changera rien.
C'est une prévention qui d
les jeunes, c'est d'avoir lar fe
extrêmportant pour les
jeunes générations. Pour les
c'est vraiment de la répressionà
feu circulent beaucoup. On aatrs
armes à feu,  en ont
partout comme ils le veulent. Il
fonça sur leur imprimante 3D
puis peuvent sortir avec ça. Ces
, il nous , il nous , il nous ,l
faut pveillance puis
il faut qu'on règle ce problème
rapidement. Plus
terrain.
- Annie, tu sais que la policelt
le jeu et le jeu et le jeu et e
la vioce qui
se prépare depuis 20 ans. Les
éléments clés de cette
ghettoïsation c'est d'a
qu'on a des taux de décrochage,
le groupe communautaire qui va
agir pour canaliser l'énergie
des jeunes de faire autre chose,
c'est important. Les budgets
vont passer de trois à
millions de dollars. On parle da
situation, c'est un, école, lest
des mères monoparentales
débordées qui n'ont pas tous les
moyens pour contrôler leurss, ds
aider ces personnes auir sur éc,
puis agir sur les jeunes. Comme
tu le dis, quand
des années avant que ça se
normalise.
- Les parents, des parents ont
été interviewés aujourd'hui.ente
Québec, le fédér
sur les armes à feu. Oncomplexe.
- Il faut que le gouvernement
mette leur culotte et prennent
leur traçabilité. On parle de
Saint-Michel auj
d'année qui touche Rivière-des-e
plateau. La situation de Saint-
erceau gang de
rue a commencé à Saint-Michel il
y a une trentaine d'années.u.u..
Mais ce qui fait que cela
ghettoïsation
moins d'accord parce que on
parle de qualité de vie. On
parle de quartiers qui sont
pauvres, de jeunes avec des
mères monoparentales qui n'ont
pas les moyens. L'école fait ce
qu'il peut. Dans Saint-Michel,
on a tous les organismes
communautaires. On a mis d
sous, on investit dans des
médiateurs urbains. En des
patrouilleurs aux écoles. À
chaque sortie d'école on a des
patrouilleurs qui sont là,
détruire des organismes
communautaires surtout à Saint-
Joseph François-Perrault qui
accompagne les jeunes, qui les
occupent, qui les empêche d'être
dans des gangs.
Ça, ça fonctionne bien mais il
faut que ça partout comme ça
dans les autres arrondissements
parce que là ça déborde la
police, son travail, cette
situation dépatouillait, maussi.
- Est-ce que la vérité le chef
sieur carram l'a
dit, en compagnie de la mère, il
a dit, ce n'est
ou 16 ans aient
des armes comme ça. On est
dépassé par ce phénomène.
- Je comprends qu'elle se
s armes et de
avoir peu de contrôle à la
frontière. Mais quelqu'un la
tient cette arme. Je comprends
que les projecte
armes parce que il y en a plus
qui en avait. Le jeune qui est
mort la station Snowdon a étéine
tôt. Et au lendemain de cet
assassinat, il y avait un jeune
qui fêtait de la musique arabe
comme s'il était dans le centre
de Chicago. Il y une culture a
changé, il y a de
l'investissement à faire sur ces
jeunes. Bien au-delà du contrôle
des armes.
- Exactement. C'est une culture.
Il est des rivalités qu'on a
peine à imaginer entre deux
écoles, de gangs, ça donne ceque
compréhension à avoir. Les
déconnecté même s'il y a
beaucoup de groupes
communautaires dans votre
quartier. Manifestement on est
déconnecté.
- Nous on avait, il y avait la
police avec les organismesavec s
locaux et les écoles. Il y avait
déjà un cercle. Dès qu'il se
passai
messages et les informations
circulaient. Ce qu'on ne voit
pas ailleurs. Ailleurs la police
de messaged, il faut vraim
contacter tout le monde. En
arrondissements, ça se passe
ensemble. Le défaut qu'on a eu
ailleurs dans d'autres
arrondissements. Que nos jeunes
font, ce qui se promène d'unarry
en a un qui a été tué
maintenant, tout dépendammentr n
autre dans le secteur qui va se
faire tirer. C'est pour ça que
la police doit jouer un rôle de
répression.
- Je vais vous donner un
exemple. Le jeune Desrochemort,e
municipal ici, je suis allé sur
les lieux. Sacré en état de choc
et la police a mis 1000 bouchées
de plus contre la guerre des
motards à cette époque. Est-ce
qu'elle en est pas devant
quelque chose qui va changer des
choses, de qui?père. Déjà on aie
premier changement. La mairesse
lorsqu'elle a prie la parole
dorénavant, bien qu'on ait
beaucoup discuté sur la
nécessité de contravail de la pt
qu'elle va falloir peut-être
venir après intervention. Elle r
au niveau judiciaire et légal,
venir à certaines mesures qui
avaien
gouvernement conservateur de
Harper, elle allait y songer.
J'aurais voulu plus que ça.
J'aurais voulu entendre
tolérance zéro. J'aurais voulu
entendre qu'elle interpelleult e
peut pas s'en laver les mains.
Les écoles oùdécrochage et on ns
annoncer la moitié arrière de la
classe ou des jeunes décrochent
en secondaire trois, c'est une u
problème.
- Merc